ouais
grosse
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission sportive minutes forme je suis
ni collages sur votre coach aujourd'hui
c'est avec moi vous allez découvrir un
nouveau mouvement nous sommes en
compagnie de johnatan bonjour johnatan
magendie falla comment ça va ça va je te
remercie respecter en forme parce que le
mouvement qui va arriver il est costaud
vous avez vu dans la première saison de
minutes forme le travail des pompes sur
un banc ou solliciter davantage la
poitrine et les épaules nous allons
passer maintenant sur les ponts crise
est au sol pour engager davantage
l'arrière des bras l'objectif de ces
compris c'est pts et de garder en
permanence des avant-bras proche de
votre buste alors vous avez deux
possibilités pour les confirmés vous
pouvez effectuer ce mouvement sur les
pointes de pieds ou sur les genoux pour
les débutants qu'on descend
tranquillement la poitrine au sol et on
repousse sur les talons de la paume de
la main
poussés et vous gardez les coûts de
proches du corps
pensez à avoir un bon gainage au niveau
du ventre pour éviter d'accentuer la
courbure du dos
et là vous allez sortir vraiment dans
vos triceps mais toi ma place alors tu
va placer les mains directement sous tes
épaules doit avancer légèrement le poids
du corps les genoux sont en retrait des
hanches
et là tu vas descendre ta poitrine sur
le sol en gardant les avant bras collés
au corps essaye de les resserrer
légèrement plus
et de repousser contact avec le sol
au niveau de la poitrine et on repousse
fort sur les paumes de mains et là vous
allez malgré tout engagé les épaules la
poitrine mais solliciter davantage au
triceps est à l'aise comme vous voulez
indiqué tout à l'heure faites le sur les
pointes de pieds pour ajouter une charge
supplémentaire tu vois mais effectue
encore de répétition laissant bien
garder coûte proche du corps repousse
fort sur les mains et garda son
abdominale serré
ok parfait tu peux t'arrêter les
sensations
ou est ce que tu sens le plus ça au
niveau des ressources avec la prise
large vous allez sortir un peu plus sa
poitrine qu'avec l'apprécierez vous
allez sentir vos triceps encore une fois
cet exercice effectué vous allez
maintenant pouvoir réaliser les
étirements correspondent à cet exercice
vous conseille de rester sur les jeunes
et voilà on restait au sol vous attrapez
le coude et vous venez glisser la main
et on m'appelait la position une
vingtaine de secondes de chaque côté je
fais la même chose de la table un
pâtissier la place et la main entre
donc tu vas chercher avec notre monde au
coude mais tu vas appuyé en direction du
talon rectangle
maintenez des come to aux étirements
entre vingt et trente secondes et vous
changez
enflammé
on s'est toujours lâcher progressivement
vos étirements affabilité de relative
blessures merci beaucoup posé car si
oui
vous donne rendez vous dans une
prochaine émission de minutes forme
garder la pêche à très bientôt merci
tonton triceps entraînez-vous de deux à
trois fois par semaine en effectuant de
trois à cinq séries de 10 à 30
répétition
conserver les coudes serrés la colonne
vertébrale neutre et les abdominaux
engagé